[Music]
but recently with Xi Jinping you know
abdullah agilent the the macron a style
of leadership or Putin's propaganda
station looking at the idea of good
leadership and the problem is at the
moment we're not having it and we have
to think about our leaders and how we
choose them I mean Xi Jinping has
concentrated power at a truly
astonishing rate at the start of this
process people joked about him being
chairman of everything and now we're in
a position where official media have
referred to him not only as wise leader
but even as my personal favorite general
secretary of people's feelings it's
quite an impressive reach isn't it so no
wonder Trump's feeling a bit jealous I
mean this is really remarkable because
China had prided itself on at least
seeming like a sort of technocracy it
kind of goes back to the 60s and the age
of ideology
Chairman Mao launched the Cultural
Revolution partly from ideological zeal
partly takes extend and shore up his
already incredible power and it was
absolutely devastating especially
actually to the political elite so if
you look at Xi Jinping's own history his
father was horribly persecuted his
half-sister died he spent years toiling
away in the countryside this was not an
unusual experience and they were all so
scarred that in the aftermath they
decided that they had to caged power you
just couldn't have one person at the
center with this much Authority so they
institutionalized power they
collectivize power they introduced all
these things like retirement ages and
term limits which is of course the thing
that she has just scrapped for himself
there was a vote within the party which
was something like 3,600 in favor and
two very brave souls against so you've
gone from the age where you had who
Jintao the world's most boring leader
probably deliberately boring and this
generation of red engineers talking
about technocracy and the scientific
theory of development to an era in which
you have Xi Jinping thought which is a
body of
theory explicitly identified as being
about one man who's in charge
indefinitely now but I think the really
key thing to remember is that this is
not as it's sometimes being portrayed
about Xi Jinping single-handedly sort of
transforming this system the point is
that the elite clearly had made this
collective decision that the system was
not sustainable that the kind of reforms
that were needed both for China's
long-term sustainability and of course
because the sustainability of Communist
Party rule depended on having a more
powerful figure at the center who could
force these changes through now I don't
think they anticipated quite how far and
how fast he'd take that and I'm pretty
sure a lot of them are regretting it now
but I think it was a collective decision
it couldn't have been done by one person
and I think there is also a lot of
genuine public enthusiasm for it there's
a lot of people who are very disturbed
but there were also a lot of people who
are buying into this and they say well
we know we like this strong leadership
and even in a system where nobody gets
to vote you still need some level of
buy-in from the people so what does this
mean for us I think it shows us that
it's really not just about leaders but
about systems and about the people
around them whether that be as in our
case the general public voting or it be
about a party and a set of institutions
and I think that means that when we
think about politics we have to think
about policy obviously and we have to
think about our leaders and how we
choose them but we also have to think
about ourselves I hope that doesn't
sound sanctimonious because I'm sure
that many of you are doing much more
than myself but we have to sort of think
about the responsibilities we have I
think that all sort of shows how
individuals as much as leaders play
their part written where the Labour
Party has been transformed at least in
the level of its membership in its
leader from what it was into something
very different which has given people
some hope again I mean you know when
Obon stands up and says things most of
these things are traditional social
democratic policies
and the attack is way out of proportion
re nationalize the railways between 65
and 70% of the British population wants
that take some of the utilities back as
soon as you can for instance water
electricity gas over 50 percent in favor
of that
and yet this proportion is never ever
reflected in what is written on the
media or on the propaganda networks of
the state I mean the British press
calmly refers to Russia today as Putin's
propaganda station which it is but the
BBC should be referred to in those terms
as well it is a propaganda station for
the dominant ideology of those who rule
and it is virtually abandoned any
critical analysis of what is going on
which once upon a time it used to do
same can be said for the bulk of the
mainstream media so in this situation
for holding to even exist is quite
amazing and why it appears more radical
than it actually is because nothing he
is said apart from foreign policy is new
it's a continuation of athlean Wilson
but he's not really got in trouble for
wanting to be nationalize the railways
it is this foreign policy elements that
we've seen this massive debate over the
summer over the attitude towards Israel
and entity anti-semitism issue what's
your take on that
my take on that is this that after the
Second Intifada these really embassies
under the direction of these droid
Foreign Office were told start labeling
opponents to Israel in our policies as
anti-semitic all over the globe well in
some cases they had more success than
others and in Britain that they had had
no success on this very little because
most of the English Jewish organizations
weren't politicized as that but recently
with Alban you see behind this I mean in
terms of actual anti-semitism it
practices in Britain it has the lowest
record of incidents reported Idaho the
whole of Europe by the way very low
proportion so you have a tiny group of
Jewish organizations opposed by other
Jews organizations Jews for B's Jews for
labor who support koban and have said
that but the publicity and the campaign
that is created is based largely largely
not exclusively on conservative Jews
with the backing of the right-wing
inside the parliamentary Labour Party
this is what's going on because there is
a layer of people within the
parliamentary Labour Party who would
rather labour lost than Obon won and
they think like that 60 or 70 of his own
MPs and they've been backing this
campaign as if suddenly anti-semitism is
ready what's the reason for that is that
Obon has had a very even-handed and
justified position on Palestine saying
that what is happening in Palestine is
unacceptable which is the position also
I would say about a 50% of Jews in this
country and an increasing number of them
in the United States especially the
young younger generation who don't want
to justify what is being done to the
Palestinians to me I suppose
looking at the idea of good leadership
it inevitably comes with reasonable
policies that come from the people they
aim to serve or at least it should come
from the people they aim to serve my
concern at the moment aside from all of
the horrors that you have just outlined
in global leadership is the idea of
strength I mean for a start off it's an
incredibly masculine idea of strength
I don't recognize Trump to be a strong
man to be perfectly honest I recognize
him to be weak weak willed easily led
and I actually just think his policy is
made up by the last person he spoke to
that day
very who sat on yeah it's just like if
you leave the room last you're the one
who's got the ideas that's the next
executive order so I think that the idea
of strength is is often just about
masculine strength and I don't
particularly think that that is good
leadership the idea that we should vote
for policies now I suppose people also
described me as being a centrist I am
NOT a centrist I am far more left-wing
than that and also that I'm a moderate I
am NOT a moderate I am a radical in
actual fact it is how I like to view
myself but the idea this sort of
centrist idea and the the macron a sort
of style of leadership or let's say let
me through that's not his name what's
his name in Canada that idea that you
are gaining your insight from the people
that you serve is a style of leadership
that I think is to me much much more
appealing although I think largely is as
false as the strength I don't think that
people just want to vote for policies
however I don't think in fact I've never
I not 21000 doors during the last snap
general election and I met one person
who'd read any manifesto I had didn't
made a single person who actually knew
anything other than the headline
policies of free university fees for
everybody from the Labour Party and
charging you to die from the
Conservative Party which admittedly did
fall down on one side in favor
hence my majority however maybe you
don't want them to the idea that people
sit and think about policy is for the
birds in my experience of my
constituents actually personality
genuinely matters much much more to the
general public than we give credit for
and therefore I think that really
actually I don't seek a world where
policy is the thing that everybody cares
about okay I just want to see a world
where the people who people follow
aren't so crazy this is the honest
immigration debate that we have got to
have and the problem is at the moment
we're not having it and we actually have
never had it and so we've now gone from
the extreme of we don't get to have a
debate about it because it's quite an
uncomfortable one because you have to
you'll be accused of calling me a racist
if I if I challenge you for your views
to the other one we've gone to the
other's extreme now where people like me
who make the point that in a city like
Nottingham where the the referendum
result was declared by ward very
effective Labour Party in Nottingham
very sensibly declared it by Ward you
know the demographics of the ward you
can see exactly without doing too much
stereotyping how people voted so where
were the biggest leave votes in
Nottingham white working-class areas and
I pointed that out
apparently that makes me a racist I mean
the world has gone could were our world
in this country it has gone completely
well I don't think so do forgive me and
then I'll shut up the problem is this
right so someone like me I have no
problem when the constituent comes up to
me and says we've got too many
immigrants in Brock stoner I'll go
really where where are they because of
course there aren't any so then I get
well they're coming really well if
they're coming these are genuine
conversations they're coming here to
work then it comes out we've got too
many Muslims do you want you a year and
what a laugh or cry you don't really
know because what you do know is that
that is not a proper debate and the
problem at the left too much at the
moment and I see this in some of
Angela's colleagues and it's not if
there's not a tribe or criticism of
labour it I understand but when now
people come then they come up to a
Labour MP and they'll say we've got too
many immigrants so they instead of
saying challenging it having the debate
they say I know I feel your pain it's we
got a problem here because they're
suppressing wages which is bollocks
it's
not true and so we are lacking again the
debate because people now don't want to
challenge frankly some racist views that
because of the referendum people think
it's acceptable to say stuff so you know
up to La Jolla not only was he the
thinker behind there this this paradigm
but also spent 15 years in Syria talking
to the communities and the society every
day and trying to understand them so
that Spiteri one of the biggest
differences between what's happening in
northern Syria right now are many other
revolutionary instances that in history
is that it's it's not a it's not a
vanguard as' movement or a revolution
that says okay we're here now and this
is the way we want you to live it's it's
built in a way that its it's command
completely embedded within its community
and within its society and therefore
that's why the most ground level of
society the communes are the where all
the decisions for society get made and I
spoke to the Arab co-chair of the
assembly
his name was Faruk and I said you know I
said to him why are you part of this you
know he he used to be an Arab tribal
leader and somewhere like you know the
Middle East if you're a tribal leader
leader the world is your oyster really
so especially in that region and I said
to him so you know why are you here and
he said you know I was one the first
stop rise against Assad and then I
experienced the seed of al Qaeda and
Isis and then I assisted in the
liberation and so he said when we first
liberated this place our motto was
education before breads and you know I I
felt like I wanted to be a part of this
revolution because it's not just for the
Kurdish people or anyone else but for
the whole region and maybe even the
world and so when I told him I do some
organizing with Kurdish students he he
he kind of he said to me why are you
just organizing Kurdish students you
should be our organizing Arab students
too so I said okay so what's your
message to them he said but actually I
don't have a message about Arabs I have
a
message for the whole of humanity and
that's you know he created criticize the
complicity and complacency of many of
the Arab states in the region especially
you know in the net in the fight against
Isis but he said my messages to humanity
and that's to support this revolution
and to recognize what we're trying to
build here and you know even though when
you kind of like go through min which
you kind of still feel some tension
because people are really still really
quite scared that you know they've more
or less just been liberated from Isis
that something else might come so I
asked them what is what do you think is
the biggest risk right now against what
you're trying to do here and every
single person I asked without a shadow
of a doubt said it's the it's the
attacks by the Turkish state and so it
made me think you know why why do
international powers one not recognized
you know the threat of the Turkish state
why why would people want to destroy a
society that's built on democracy
ecology and you know gender equality
isn't that why you know for why a lot of
the time in the West we start wars
against countries in the first place you
know so-called like bomb them to
democracy like that's usually usually
the policy or you know whatever the
rationale behind it and so you know I
realized that any kind of autonomy of
any people a ground level that it's not
by a a central authoritarian government
means that the interests of whether it's
international powers or international
local powers can't be cut won't won't
work in the way it has for especially
the past 100 years so that's when I
realized you know what I really had no
clue what struggle was until I met these
people you know we we we kind of like
speak about these things in an abstract
way all the time and you know struggle
revolution resistance but when you see
that in those conditions despite those
conditions that people are still not
motivated by fear or hate but rather by
the hope that they they can be active
actors in transforming where they are
but maybe even having an impact on the
whole world the democracy that we enjoy
the very limited democracy that we enjoy
in the advanced capitalist societies and
political scientists of every
ideological stripe agree with this
cannot be understood apart from the
formation of organizations of the un--
propertied who demanded that they be
included in the state dislike being
UNPROFOR m-- of represent elected
representation we had before jacksonian
democracy in the united states first of
all a night not sure any go three miles
if you was in this job which et is
related to it it was the development of
labor movements and the development of
feminist movements after that supported
usually by these labor movements arguing
that the unpro purty or human beings
were considered the properties of the
men and their family should be able to
be members of the state and the
democracy we have which is a real valued
and important thing was won by those
struggles it didn't come out of an
abstract model it didn't come into the
beneficence of the old state ruling
class it was one everywhere and this is
entirely agreed in political science
there was a great deal of socialist
yearning often associated this with this
but not for the most part that socialist
yearning that yearning for collective
protection collective expression an
attempt to democratize our society to
democratize the enterprise to allow what
happens on the hospital ward to be a
matter of discourse and discussion of a
democratic kind to allow what happens in
the mine to be that was what you
for that has not been achieved that has
not been achieved well we have a three
National Health Service here which is
free I was speaking of the Democratic
aspiration what we have is a society in
which the decisions about what is to be
produced where it's to be produced
what's to be invested how it's to be
invested is not determined by States it
is determined by the massive
corporations that control the economies
they do so of course in close
conjunction with the states that protect
their property that codify the rules of
exchange around the world so we have it
is important democracy but we have a
yearning which Corbyn expresses for a
much broader a much deeper democratic
economy democratic society full of what
you do well if you read the labor
manifesto it begins with developing the
coop system providing an infrastructure
through it for it through regional
investment banks in my view eventually
although this would meet enormous
opposition not only from the City of
London but I fear from parts of the
British state which are the repressive
apparatus of the state to turn what we
all need so badly and are now so stuck
into to turn the city of London into a
public utility this is what all of our
resources pass through right and without
access to that we can't democratically
decide what should be produced how it
should be produced whether the NHS
should be marketized
which is what's happened to it to watch
all the full talks and debates from
these highlights find the link below in
the description and subscribe today to
the Institute's of art and ideas
you